et pour en parler nous sommes avec eric
revel pour aller plus loin pardon
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous on
voit que cette question est une question
compliquée et en particulier pour le
gouvernement oui c'est une question à la
fois politique mais c'est aussi quand
même une question d'humanité
pardon alors on a entendu dans ce
reportage la position du miz affaires
étrangères on comprend bien l'embarras
des uns et des autres mais moi je vais
vous donner mon point de vue il vaut ce
qu'il vaut
autant je pense qu'on doit se poser la
question pour les adultes de les
rapatrier ou pas parce que quelqu'un qui
est parti faire le djihad de son plein
gré dans un pays qui est un adulte
pardonnez moi mais on peut se poser la
question de savoir si des toujours
radicaliser et je vais même plus loin
celui qui a commis des attentats dans un
pays précis que ce soit en syrie en irak
wire pour moi s'il est adulte il doit
être jugé dans ce pays maintenant la
question des enfants la question des
enfants qui sont issus de couples de
djihadistes parce que vous avez aussi
des femmes qui sont partis faire le
djihad parfois d'ailleurs contrainte
parfois elles ont choisi cette voie ces
enfants n'ont pas demandé à naître ces
enfants ils ont la plupart du temps
puisqu'ils sont issus d'un couple de
djihadiste français entre guillemets ils
ont la nationalité française alors moi
je pense qu'il est il serait plus
raisonnable d'essayer de les rapatrier
tous pour une raison très simple d'avoir
via la question d'humanité mais aussi
une question qu'on doit se poser si on
laisse ces jeunes enfants issus de
couples jihadistes dans un pays où le
djihad continue de faire des ravages il
ne faudra pas s'étonner que lorsqu'ils
atteindront 15 saisons ou même avant il
porte à nouveau la flamme du djihad
contre les pays occidentaux comme comme
comme le nôtre donc cette question du
rapatriement des enfants au delà la
question d'humanité c'est aussi une
question de stratégie j'avais dire est
ce qu'on veut les laisser là bas pour en
faire des individus qui se radicalisent
rond ou est-ce qu'on veut essayer après
tourne à la patrie des droits de l'homme
de l'est de les rapatrier en france dans
les meilleures conditions alors le thème
avait dit oui en tout cas jean yves
raude le drian a réaffirmé que paris
continuera bien sûr de rapatrier ses
ressortissants mineurs depuis la série
sauf que
c'est vrai qu'il ya souvent deux à vis
notamment l'opinion publique est
relativement contre en majorité à un
conte ce rapatriement
craignant peut-être parfois je cite des
bombes à retardement
tout cela pour dire que c'est une
question ou qui peut s'avérer compliqué
politiquement notamment en période
électorale
oui et puis d'ailleurs certains
candidats aux proches de candidats
parfois on dit n'importe quoi par
exemple sandrine rousseau qui hélas
proche de yannick jadot l'écologie
europe les verts avaient dit il faut
rapatrier tous les adultes radicaliser
qui sont à l'extérieur qu'on les
surveille ira mieux en france soyez bon
c'est pas une caricature puisqu'elle l'a
2 en revanche c'est vrai que cette
question je commençais par là devient
politique on est dans un contexte
d'élections présidentielles évidemment
abordé la question du rapatriement des
enfants ou des djihadistes et aborder la
question du terrorisme est immédiatement
évidemment on poserait où on posera des
questions sur le bilan comment le
gouvernement actuel a fait face bien ou
pas bien au terrorisme et je pense que
ce sujet là me semble utile personne n'a
intérêt ce qu'il soit mis même s'il est
majeur dans la corbeille de départ de
cette élection ça sera selon vous malgré
tout un enjeu réel de de campagne le
terrorisme parce qu'on parle beaucoup de
pouvoir d'achat en parle aussi de
sécurité d'immigration peut-être moins
parfois de terrorisme
moi je n'ai pas le sentiment que c'est
un thème qui sera mis sur la table sauf
évidemment c'est absolument pas souhaité
sauf si un nouvel acte de terrorisme
évidemment avait lieu en métropole ou
dans un territoire d'outre-mer mais je
ne pense pas que ce soit un thème qui va
jaillir naturellement sur la table même
si la france a beaucoup souffert de tous
ces attentats j'ai pas l'impression pour
l'instant les candidats s'en empare on
rappelle le pouvoir d'achat la santé la
sécurité l'immigration ça ce sont les
quatre thèmes qui dans tous les sondages
intéresse les français merci beaucoup
eric à revel de nous avoir apporté votre
décryptage